muriel bowser hosted a large wedding
mask list after the mandate went into
place
invested in me as mayor of washington dc
which will someday be the 51st state
it doesn't apply to them it doesn't
apply to them because they're special
now here's the thing we have set up a
society at this point where the elites
are not bound by any of this i've seen
this over and over and over
we saw experts in the uk who would
recommend that everybody mask up and
stay in their homes but they had to meet
their lover on the side it was very
important and so they just broke
quarantine and broke protocol we had
chris cuomo lecturing everybody
on the importance of how to act during
this pandemic while simultaneously
covering up for his brother's
malfeasance and also
leaving quarantine in order to go check
out a house that he was building
and now over the weekend we saw a wide
variety of democrats engaging
in covet hypocrisy so for example
muriel bowser decided that it was deeply
important just hours
before the mass mandate went into place
to go take an
unmasked photo with dave chappelle i
mean hey when you have the opportunity
to take a photo with dave chappelle
covet guidelines go by the wayside
according to the washington examiner
washington dc mayor muriel bowser got in
a maskless photo with comedian dave
chappelle before her mandate requiring
face coverings went into effect
on saturday john falcitio the deputy the
district's deputy mayor for planning an
economic development tweeted a photo
friday of himself bowser chappelle and
two others together inside a room
chappella native of the district
performed at the anthem a local
entertainment venue to a sold-out crowd
the venue announced ahead of the show
masks were required to be worn at all
times
although it's unclear where exactly the
photo was taken
bowser had announced on thursday that
effective on 5 am saturday every person
older than 2
must wear a mask indoors regardless of
vaccination status
but apparently that no longer applied to
muriel bowser
right that muriel bowser she's special
she's a special and that means
that we don't have to worry about that
by the way the rolling day seven day
death average
in washington dc according to the new
york times
zero zero so here's the thing muriel
bowser is acting like a normal person
should act
she's vaccinated she's safe
she's acting normally in her life but
she's preaching that everybody else
including the vaccinated needs to mask
up then over the weekend
she also hosted a large wedding mask
list after the mandate
went into place here's some video of
muriel bowser
presiding over a wedding this is
outdoors she's still very very close to
people
and then of course they moved indoors
and she was taking photos of people
vested in me as mayor of washington dc
which will someday be the 51st day
i now pronounce you husband and wife
um it's not gonna be the 51st date and
also i noticed that um
after this she then went inside and uh
it was a five-star hotel in adams morgan
and everybody inside was dancing
maskless i noticed
really solid stuff bowser's office sent
fox 5 a statement that said
mayor bowser officiated an outdoor
rooftop wedding ceremony followed by an
indoor dinner the mayor wore a mask in
doors in compliance with mandate the
organizers and venue staff worked to
create a safe environment for the staff
and guests weird because i'm looking at
the pictures right now
and i'm noticing that there are a lot of
people who are not masked indoors wow i
mean
so disastrous so terrible by the way
barack obama is planning a birthday bash
he's planning his 60th birthday hundreds
of guests on martha's vineyard
now i i've been told that large-scale
gatherings
are a danger to us and others that even
with masks i mean let's be frank
people can pass this thing we have been
told
but barack obama's birthday party is
different it's like a george floyd
protest or something last summer
it is so important that covid no longer
applies
francis collins literally said if you're
talking about a small party like i might
have at my house for six or eight people
who are all fully vaccinated i don't
believe we need to put on masks to be
next door to each other but if there are
100 people and of course how are you
really going to be sure about people's
vaccination status
apparently there will be some safety
measures put in place obama officials
did not say whether guests will be
required
to wear masks and they are they're
holding the party at the former first
family's 12 million
home which sits on 30 oceanfront acres
it's good to be an ex-president of the
united states
steven spielberg will show up pearl jam
is set to play
obviously these people are treating the
pandemic with all of the grave care
that they say that we should treat it
with also chicago mayor lori lightfoot
who you'll remember very early on in the
pandemic really really needed a haircut
and so she violated her
pandemic protocols to go get a haircut
she um she held a
music festival in chicago lollapalooza
she also went and visited it apparently
she actually attended it
and she was caught with her mask off
while hanging with the celebrities here
is a picture of lollapalooza
over the weekend do you see a mask
anywhere in the crowd anywhere mueller
euler did you see any masks
nope not seeing any masks are you weird
look at that people all crammed all
close together
not masked look at this i mean
this is all coveted safe though because
after all lots of lefties go to
lollapalooza so you know it's fine it's
probably fine
probably nothing to worry about right
definitely not a super spreader event
this by the way is indoors and you can
see a lot of people unmasked
so that's that's great chicago tribune
reporter gregory pratt said quote
at the same time she's threatening
possible restrictions if cases rise
above 200 per day
mayor lori lightfoot is moving forward
to bring with plans to bring a hundred
thousand a day
to grant park for lollapalooza
so that is uh that is very solid stuff
right there
it's um very very good
really really nice three days of music
euphoria with a huge maskless crowd as
described by
lori garrett who is a
person who writes for uh the center on
foreign relations
again it doesn't apply to them it
doesn't apply to them because they're
special they're special again here's the
reality
everybody should act how they want
they're adults now
you want to get a vaccine get a vaccine
you don't want to get a vaccine i think
you're wrong you should get a vaccine
but if you don't that's on you you then
get covered you end up in the hospital
that's also on you but
no one apparently like there's just no
interest on the left
in allowing this pandemic to end because
for them the pandemic ending is zero
coven
because they understand zero code will
never be achieved and because zero code
will never be achieved
this means they will have total control
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content